man you just feel the pressure you know
it's like haha here we go starting to
the galaxy vol 2 so guardians of the
galaxy 2 is the sequel to the very
successful generally beloved guardians
of the galaxy in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but this is like what a 15th
movie in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
only [ __ ] Peter quill aka star-lord
finds his father played by Kurt Russell
he saw that in the trailer I thought it
was weird show it in the trailer you do
find that out pretty fast like okay I
didn't actually spoil anything and some
of the other guardians go on some other
adventures and there's gold people now
we have a movie to review a movie that
yes not as good as the first moment
pretty commonplace among movie sequels
doesn't always happen now I mean Winter
Soldier I was like oh [ __ ] by better you
mean [ __ ] better before I get to the
end the bummers I'm talking about what I
liked first was surprisingly yondu was
great rock it was a standout for me in
the first guardians movie this movie
yondu of all people it is some good
stuff with this character in fact if
they want to make a yondu movie I'd be
totally fine with that baby Groot is as
cute as you want him to be and the movie
does have some entertaining good-looking
action as are Kurt Russell was a great
addition to the guardians of the galaxy
universe or I guess Marvel Cinematic
Universe guardians of the galaxy is the
most detached of the Marvel movies but
still takes place in that universe and I
thought Kurt Russell was really good for
his role in this movie
seeing him and star-lord bond was
actually a good arc in a movie granted
it's pretty much 90% of the movie but if
you're just looking at that element it
was a good element and Kurt Russell did
a good job in it accent let's get to the
first movie from the set up doesn't
really flow it's a bit disjointed you're
like what's the point of this and then
they're hanging out with Kurt Russell
and you're like alright I guess we're
hanging out here and then there's this
jailbreak scenario it just really it did
guardians are jailed star-lord is
hanging out with Kurt Russell
it's the movie and just throw some
exciting action in it there's this arc I
guess arc with these gold people's a
civilization of people their gold and
they worked totally fine for the
introduction because you want to see
them do a mission and then alright they
get out of that mission then they go off
to do some other stuff but like a bad
herpes flyer up every so often in this
movie it's a bunch of ships and Armada
of gold people ships just come in to
wreak some havoc and then they go away
and come back it was a bit disjointed
it's like why are you guys here can't we
have something else that's more attached
to ego the Living Planet doing something
they didn't
really sick in the movie really Drax
didn't do much gomorrah did a little
more than Drax did because of nebula
nebula and Gamora are a really good
saving grace when nebula in particular
in her dynamic with Gamora it's positive
and negative there for sure fabula is
great because we find out that Thanos is
a dick in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
you actually haven't seen Thanos be a
dick in fact the only reason you know
Thanos is an [ __ ] is because you're
nerdy sweaty friend told you Santos is
an [ __ ]
other than that movie you wouldn't
really know but because of nebula you
get a first-hand account and stories
that she has when she's talking about
Thanos you're like oh that guy is a day
I loved that panelist is nowhere in this
movie at all but it was great to
actually hear some shitty horror stories
about him really like yeah that is a
piece of [ __ ] he needs to be stopped
however she is overcooking it a little
bit in the acting she always talks like
this pipe down
chill out doesn't need to be that
intense all the time you can actually be
a broken hurt person and not talk like
that it kind of feels like I came into
American Horror Story a little later so
I didn't see the early seasons which I
hear are the better seasons but even
when I came into it which was American
Horror Story freak show it really felt
like everyone in this show was in a
contract to be on the show
they just didn't always have a place for
everybody so they had to just make these
[ __ ] arcs to put them somewhere I
feel like that's the pressure guardians
to spilling of all these characters
great star-lord is going to meet his dad
great that's going to be the main point
of the story great what are the other
people going to do I don't know when you
have an ensemble and the main point of
the story concentrates on one among an
ensemble it's going to compromise
everyone else really I think it's
impossible to work around I just feel
like this movie didn't do the smoothest
job in order around that I feel like
guardians of the galaxy you had the
concept like well people love the humor
in the first movie we're going to have
more humor in this movie but we're going
to compromise the flow of the plot the
characters we're going to rush the movie
out and by jokes I mean there were a lot
of jokes in this movie yes the humor in
guardians of the galaxy is a staple of
guardians of the galaxy but this had so
much humor and so little else that you
can't help but be like all the humor had
better land if you're going to do that
and not all of it did like at one point
in this movie this joke was going on for
so long and actually had to pull myself
out of the movie I was like oh my god
this joke is still happening guys in the
end guardians of the galaxy vol 2 had
enjoyment in it baby Groot was cute
rocket has some great lines great
moments
dude was awesome I enjoyed the humor
when it landed however the build-up was
choppy the execution as a homeless job
you just felt like the movie was rushed
or in a world where you hear Joss Whedon
was burned out from age of Ultron maybe
James Gunn was burned out in this one I
don't know I don't know the reason it
was really talking it around my brain
but this is how I say it in the end I
would probably not watch guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 again I just don't have
the urge to I enjoyed the enjoyable
parts of it and it's kind of rolled my
eyes at the part I didn't enjoy maybe a
beer will make it go down better so in
the end I will say guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 would probably be a better
time if I were drunky and now there's a
party blackford comment sections going
to suck 15 movies in they can't all be
gold they're not going to all be gold I
will say I feel like the reviews and the
spectrum of reviews gonna be vast when I
walked out this movie some people are
like I loved it other people were like
eise's alright I don't think there's
going to be unanimous so when you're
watching reviews out there don't take
one reviewer watch a spectrum of people
and be like alright I kind of I can take
a little bit of that a little bit of
that I feel like I'll know if I'm going
to watch it [ __ ] it just watch it
yourself then if that's what they're not
you're like that the reception of the
screening I was that was very different
than just my take on it alright guys the
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 have you
seen it what did you think about it a
little early this review so I don't
think a lot of you have seen it yet
double do a spectrum of two what are
your favorite and least favorite movies
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe thus
far whatever they are whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]